los líderes del g7 reunidos en Hiroshima
para celebrar la Cumbre económica
Joe biden
el presidente Lula y Emmanuel macón
están presentes para iniciar los debates
el objetivo presentar un frente Unido
contra Rusia y China la guerra en
Ucrania es uno de los temas centrales
sobre la mesa los líderes del g7 ya han
expresado su apoyo humanitario y
financiero al país y Rusia fue
inmediatamente objeto de sanciones
económicas
nuestra prioridad ahora es bloquear su
margen de maniobra y seguir privando a
Rusia de sus recursos esenciales
restringiremos la compra de diamantes
rusos los diamantes rusos no son eternos
explicaremos abierta y francamente
porque estas sanciones son necesarias y
están justificadas
la propaganda rusa se basa en mentiras y
conspiraciones nuestra respuesta son
hechos y cifras
otros temas sobre con esa energía clima
coordinación económica pero es el
expediente chino y la Espinosa coyuntura
de Taiwán en el que los países del g7
tendrán que ponerse de acuerdo Los
europeos especialmente Francia y
Alemania no quieren romper lazos con
china uno de los mayores mercados
económicos del mundo
necesitamos comprometernos con china en
cuestiones globales cambio climático
protección de los recursos naturales
biodiversidad desarrollo sostenible dado
su lugar en la comunidad internacional
otra cuestión del g7 armas nucleares
algunos líderes como el japonéshida
quieren animar al grupo de los siete
hacer transparentes sobre sus armas y a
reducir su Arsenal nuclear especialmente
el del Reino Unido Francia y Estados
Unidos que tienen miles de ojivas
nucleares